[Música]
el consejo de seguridad de naciones
unidas se reunió de manera
extraordinaria aunque no dieron
conclusiones de la sesión embajador
ucraniano denunció que rusia está
utilizando bombas de vacío están
prohibidas por el convenio de gines
[Música]
después de dos días de toque de queda
total los habitantes de kiev volvieron a
las calles para abastecerse y unos
aprovecharon para intentar salir de la
capital ucraniana sin embargo la
prohibición de salir de casa sigue
aplicándose durante las noches
la mitad de la humanidad vive en zonas
que están en peligro por la crisis
climática yo advirtió el segundo de los
tres reportes que publican los expertos
climáticos de la onu este informe del
ipcc sus siglas en inglés se centra en
los impactos la adaptación y la
vulnerabilidad
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle y
comenzamos en nueva york el lunes se
reunió de manera extraordinaria la
asamblea general de la onu es que el
consejo de seguridad si toda la reunión
para intentar superar el bloqueo de
rusia en este último organismo en la
asamblea general buscan que dos tercios
de los países respalden una resolución
para condenar los ataques rusos contra
ucrania a diferencia del consejo de
seguridad allí ningún país tiene la
capacidad de veto sin embargo las
resoluciones de la asamblea no son
jurídicamente vinculantes pero si tienen
un peso político en el intento de aislar
a rusia esta resolución en particular se
votará el próximo miércoles por su parte
del consejo de seguridad también tuvo
una sesión para debatir lo que está
ocurriendo en ucrania es de nueva york
nuestra corresponsal ma bensalah nos
explicó previamente por qué se reunieron
y que se debatió en el consejo de
seguridad hoy el consejo de seguridad se
ha reunido a petición de francia para
tratar todas las cuestiones las
consecuencias humanitarias
esta crisis ha comenzado con la
intervención de rusia diciendo que 12
miembros de su misión han sido
expulsados de eeuu dice estados unidos
que por llevar a cabo actividades que no
le corresponden la respuesta de eeuu en
este consejo ha sido que ellos no se
están reuniendo esta tarde para eso sino
para tratar las consecuencias
humanitarias ha dicho que la invasión
premeditada y sin provocación de rusia
ucrania está provocando una crisis
humanitaria que el organismo las el
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
debe abordar y debe también poner medios
para que se cumpla la ley internacional
y los derechos humanos en hago lo que
todos han coincidido que es ayuda
humanitaria es necesaria incluso rusia
ha estado de acuerdo con eso pero ha
dicho que ellos no han comenzado esta
guerra que ellos lo que están haciendo
es intentar terminar la acusado a
ucrania de comenzar esta guerra en el
2014 dice que sus objetivos no son los
civiles pero ucrania le responde con con
una con números con cifras dice que
hasta el momento ha muerto 352 personas
entre ellos 16 niños dice que las tropas
rusas están bombardeando hospitales
orfanato ambulancias y además ha sido
también muy emotivo el hecho de que ha
cerrado su discurso diciendo que a pesar
de que la medianoche es el momento más
peligroso cuando más miedo hay tiene
ganas de que llegue porque será el
momento en el que rusia termine la
presidencia del consejo de seguridad que
este mes le toca a él presidir la
ucrania ha dicho también que además
mañana se lanzará una plataforma
electrónica humanitaria para recoger
ayuda y poder distribuirla ha dicho que
ahora mismo esos corredores humanitarios
son más necesarios que nunca en la
asamblea general el secretario de la onu
antonio guterres advirtió que espera que
el conflicto en ucrania no se eleve a un
nivel nuclear sus declaraciones llegaron
un día después de que el presidente ruso
vladimir putin pusiera en alerta máxima
a las fuerzas de disuasión son las que
manejan el armamento nuclear del país
esa fue su respuesta a lo que consideró
medidas poco amistosas por parte de
occidente en el siguiente informe les
contamos cuál es la capacidad nuclear de
moscú
vladimir putin llevo la apuesta cuando
ordenó poner a las fuerzas de disuasión
de rusia que manejan armas nucleares en
alerta máxima un movimiento alarmante
dado que moscú tiene el mayor arsenal
nuclear del mundo según el instituto
internacional de investigación para la
paz de estocolmo el año pasado rusia
tenía más de 6 mil ojivas un poco más
que su rival estadounidense de estas
rusia tiene más de 1600 ojivas
desplegadas lo que significa que están
ubicadas en bases de misiles o para
bombardeos listas para ser disparadas en
un plazo relativamente corto entre el
arsenal ruso hay un arma conocida por su
nombre en clave de la otan satán 2 ls 28
armas el mayor misil balístico
intercontinental jamás fabricado las
autoridades rusas afirman que su alcance
supera los 10.000 kilómetros y es capaz
de llevar entre 10 y 15 ojivas nucleares
lo que significa que podría destruir un
territorio del tamaño de francia
occidente teme que un posible cambio
constitucional del aliado de rusia
belarús pueda permitir misiles nucleares
en su suelo lo que podría hacer que
moscú nuevas sus devastadoras armas
cerca de la zona y no sabemos lo que
significa que belarús tenga presencia
nuclear en su territorio significa que
rusia podría colocar armas nucleares en
belarús y este es un camino muy
peligroso
al igual que otros estados con armas
nucleares mosco ha utilizado su
capacidad principalmente para disuadir y
no es la primera vez que putin hace
tales amenazas las fuerzas nucleares
rusas también se pusieron en alerta
máxima durante la anexión de crimea en
el 2014 para aplazar cualquier
represalia el lunes por la mañana
terminó un largo toque de queda para los
habitantes de kiev muchos pasaron el fin
de semana en refugios ante antiaéreos en
medio de los bombardeos rusos ahora
algunos intentan salir de la capital
ucraniana mientras otros quieren
abastecerse para los próximos días vamos
con el informe
largas filas frente a las farmacias de
kiev los ucranianos se están
abasteciendo después de dos días de
toque de queda por fin pueden salir como
esto yo sé que ahora voto mi marido ha
tenido un ataque al corazón y necesito
medicinas para él y no todas las
farmacias están abiertas a su sueño
capstone los castreños sueño ser
chequera 27 han predictivo el anterior
si usted no se puede predecir nada
tienes altibajos es muy difícil sentirse
así especialmente cuando tienes que
hablar con tu familia con tus hijos
tienes que mantenerte fuerte y no
mostrar que tienes miedo cuando
realmente lo tienes esas freight patio
de freight soy un hombre que no tiene
tiempo para esperar pasa una lista de
medicamentos
antes del juego detrás de panza
al estar fuera se arriesgan y ya están
prácticamente acostumbrados al sonido de
las sirenas que suenan con regularidad
algunos compran para los ucranianos que
se han levantado en armas contra los
rusos
enviamos dinero les proporcionamos todo
tipo de cosas nadie esperaba esta
situación un boxeador me pidió que le
consiguió unos calcetines así que compré
algunos y todo cuesta el doble el precio
habitual super expansor light weiss es
masas bild mientras las calles de
quiebre están prácticamente desiertas la
estación de tren está muy concurrida
y terminamos con noticias de medio
ambiente porque este lunes salió el más
reciente informe del grupo
intergubernamental sobre el cambio
climático de la onu el ipcc por sus
siglas en inglés el segundo de tres que
publicará sus conclusiones son
particularmente alarmantes ya que su
escenario más optimista prevé la
extinción de entre el 3 y el 14 por
ciento de las especies animales y
vegetales de la tierra los detalles los
trae gabriel coche un informe alarmante
el último reporte de la ips indica que
cerca de la mitad del planeta está
afectado por el calentamiento global la
cifra de nuestro informe indica que
entre 33 y 36 mil millones de personas
en el mundo son vulnerables a la crisis
climática también la naturaleza sufre
amenazas ya irreversibles en algunos
casos sólo con un calentamiento de 15
grados celsius encima de las
temperaturas pre industriales el 14% de
las especies animales y vegetales se
enfrentarían a un riesgo de extinción y
en el peor de los escenarios con un
calentamiento de 5 grados hasta el 48
por ciento de las especies terrestres
correrían este riesgo las poblaciones
más afectadas se encuentran en países
africanos y el sur de asia pero también
las que viven en zonas marginales de
países ricos como estados unidos las
islas y los litorales están
particularmente en peligro la
consecuencia aún más presión migratoria
en el mundo
cada año yo diría que entre 20 y 40
millones de personas se ven desplazadas
por fenómenos climáticos extremos y cada
año esta cifra duplica o triplica el
número de personas desplazadas por los
conflictos o la violencia así que hay
una necesidad realmente apremiante de
desarrollar respuestas políticas para
proteger los derechos de esas personas
wright autos vivos en esta línea el
informe insiste en la necesidad de una
acción inmediata y la capacidad
creciente de adaptación de la población
hay una ventana breve y que se cierra
rápidamente para asegurar un futuro
habitable en el planeta tenemos que
estar a la altura de este reto es la
década decisiva de la acción climática
kate of climate exit tanto los gobiernos
como el sector privado la sociedad civil
deben actuar para limitar la subida de
las aguas la inseguridad alimentaria y
las sequías entre otros retos globales
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]